mes chers compatriotes je suis candidat
à la présidence de la république
c'est une décision grave
je me suis résolu après mûre réflexion
j'ai 48 ans je suis maire de paris aussi
loin que je remonte dans le temps
je ne trouve parmi mes ancêtres que
paysan et instituteurs enraciné dans
cette terre de corrèze dont je suis le
député mon enfance a été marquée bien
sûr par la guerre et ses malheurs et mes
études terminées
j'ai été soldat en algérie j'ai commencé
ma vie publique en 1967 comme ministre
du général de gaulle et de georges
pompidou en 1974
je me suis efforcé de tous mes moyens
d'écarter le danger que représentait
pour la france
l'élection du candidat du programme
commun et ce risque dissiper j'ai pensé
que notre pays reprendrait sa marche en
avant
j'ai donc accepté d'être premier
ministre et lorsque j'ai constaté que la
politique menée conduisait à
l'affaiblissement de la france
alors j'ai décidé de me retirer et
aujourd'hui j'ai observé que si je
n'étais pas candidat vous seriez
contraint au même choix qu'en 1974 choix
désespérant entre une politique qui a
échoué
et alors cela représenterait 14 ans et
une politique qui risquerait fort
d'engager la france sur la voie de la
vente sûrs
depuis deux mois je parcours nos
provinces de métropole et d'outre-mer et
j'ai constaté votre inquiétude devant la
situation économique qui se dégrade
votre angoisse devant le chômage la
hausse des prix les inégalités qui
s'accroissent et la position de la
france dans le monde qui se dégrade
c'est pourquoi je vous propose
aujourd'hui le renouveau dans la
sécurité parce que j'ai observé
également que notre peuple avait la
volonté de faire l'effort nécessaire
le renouveau s'est allégé le poids de
l'état et de l'administration pour
libérer l'instinct de création d'un
peuple fort seul le progrès économique
permettra de réduire le chômage la
sécurité c'est d'abord la sécurité
politique élu je disposerai aussitôt
d'une majorité donc pas de dissolution
pas de trouble pas de perte de temps
la sécurité c'est également le respect
de la parole donnée
j'ai pris des engagements j'en ai fixé
le calendrier et je m'y tiendrai
ce programme clair doit être mise en
oeuvre pour la france et pourtant et
pourtant on essaye de vous faire peur on
vous explique qu'il y aurait comme une
fatalité qui vous conduirai à devoir au
deuxième tour choisir toujours entre les
deux mêmes candidats du passé celui dont
la politique a déçu et celui dont la
politique inquiète
eh bien pourquoi votre choix serait-il
ainsi limiter le candidat dont la
politique inquiète ne sera pas battu par
la résignation
il le sera bien sûr mais par la volonté
et l'espérance que je vous propose
croyez moi le moment est venu de tourner
la page ce qui est important est
toujours simple si vous voulez le
renouveau dans la sécurité à leur
exprimer le dès le premier tour pour ne
pas être enfermé dans le second dans un
choix entre la stagnation ou l' aventure
mes chers compatriotes ne vous en
laissez pas compter vous qui avez
confiance dans la france choisisse et
l'espoir
choisissez l'avenir